what up Squad guess what trash taste has
partnered up with the folks over at
gamer Subs to bring to you the very own
trash test waifu cup look at this these
cups are a one-time limited edition drop
that will never be released again as you
can see we've been constantly drinking
out of these gamer Subs cups and they've
given us our own special Cup this time
which is only available for two weeks of
course you love drinking RGB and you can
do that with every single game of Subs
flavor in your very own trash taste
gamer cup look at the girl on the front
cute as hell yeah I think especially
like female make is it well yeah we had
one design each also you're doing like
the JoJo yeah yeah you are you are doing
the job yeah it's me oh that's an
attractive woman damn look at those
tears giant badonkadonks love what they
did there I'm JoJo posing of course so
if you want to grab one for yourself use
our code trash taste and click the link
down in the description below and with
the episode when I wake up on the wrong
side of the bed and I'm just like
that's right why would I want to do this
because it's a cool vocal effect
oh so you can sound like you're in Dune
what's up you humid Hombres welcome back
to another episode of trash days podcast
I could [ __ ] hear like your gears
turning your brain as you're just like I
gotta think of something
ombre is that the chronic correct no I
just love seeing it like that it's like
it's like saying Jose instead of Jose
yeah
Spanish language
oh it's a pitbull album right yeah uh
dale dale dale dale right yeah jalapeno
avocado chill happen okay
yeah I am hombre number one with hombre
number two and three we're the Hombres
we're the Hombres today you've just been
click baited baby
we're not leaving Japan no we haven't
been click baited because we are leaving
Japan sure technically in a sense in a
sense if you leave your family to come
back you still left your hand yeah this
is just sounds dramatic yeah so you
won't clickbaiter you were just
guys I'm leaving and then walking out
that's the difference and I am not
returning for a considerable amount of
time yes which is which is basically
what every YouTuber does like when
someone says I'm leaving YouTube or
something it's just like oh someone's
burnt out needs a break okay okay okay I
get it I get it you need you need one
more like YouTuber video to like gain
the clicks before you go on your holiday
this is that YouTube video
yeah we'll we'll explain why in a second
but like can I I want to make a quick
announcement okay for myself if if you
would let me okay
um I started my own clothing brand oh
did you actually I'm wearing it right
now oh [ __ ] yeah I was gonna ask guys
so yeah I've been working on this for
like a year right uh in secret oh nice
yeah yeah like they didn't know about it
I'm like oh what
so uh yeah uh By the time this episode
comes out it will be like pretty much
close to launch okay so I figured while
we're here I'll uh just announce it
nice nice it's called nonsense okay I
was gonna ask if it's called [ __ ] that
noise
so this is just this is just uh this is
just one of them actually Kai can you
upstairs and get uh the other shirt I
have
but yeah
um so this episode is sponsored by Joey
this episode is sponsored by me oh yeah
we're getting a car
you get mates
yeah but
um you know I figured
like this would be the perfect
opportunity to like announce it
um yeah I have another shirt here what
made you decide to start working on
um
I like drip yeah you know yeah and it's
like there's a lot of drip I like and
there's a lot of drip I like wearing but
like you know what better way to flaunt
out my drip than to just make mine just
make uh yeah so this is literally one
I'll do it myself I'll do it myself so
this is the long tea right okay oh that
looks nice back designs like this oh
that's nice you can check that out but
yeah
um yeah damn what a business Mogul
business Mogul yeah very nice very thin
yes look at this entrepreneur
I can call myself an entrepreneur
finally business starter you're gonna
put in your Twitter yeah yeah of course
I have to know don't do that nonsense
found him I have to do that nonsense
founder and CEO but uh yeah so I've been
working on this brand thing for like a
year now great pitch
thank you for that to be that loud I'm
so sorry but yeah I've been working on
this for like a year now
um and you know like I've always been
known to like you know wear good clothes
yeah like I like you know I'm privileged
I'm privileged I'm privileged to wear
Google but you know I've always been
like interested in like clothing like
fashion you know like streetwear stuff
like that so I was like yeah there's so
much good street wear out there but like
nothing that was like really like
speaking to me personally right it's
like there's a lot of good brands and
whatnot but it's like so I was just like
I'll [ __ ] do it myself I'll make it a
pain in the ass yeah absolutely it was a
pain in the ass yeah yeah so like um
yeah so it's like a full-on proper brand
or anything and like the one thing I was
always scared of right is like whenever
YouTube is released clothes yeah it's
usually under the merch yeah yeah right
but like I didn't want this to be much
because it's like because you know these
designs and like all the designs are
going to be releasing have nothing to do
with me or like the likeness of me or
anything like that yeah I wanted to just
be like something separate to me right
that like in the case that like the
anime man or whatever just [ __ ]
implodes in on itself right in a couple
years time that this can still be around
right so he's like I'm already not
watching an anime exactly it's already
it's already on the Dire Straits all
right back up exactly it's already on
the Dire Straits I'm like you know what
like I'll I'll try something new I'll
try something like challenging yeah yeah
so uh yeah so by the time this episode
is out like all the Social Media stuff
is probably ready to go we literally
didn't know anything about it we we
didn't know anything
you don't know you don't understand how
hard it was to keep it a secret I'm like
Joey's kept a secret from us
like literally I started this before we
moved to this office are you serious
yeah like at the old office what yeah so
it's been like over a year now okay so
yeah I'm uh I'm very passionate about
this and I wanted to do well and uh I
have so I have so many questions I don't
know where to start it's all
everything's designed by me as well like
sketched by me obviously I obviously I
obviously got designers and everything
to clean it up and everything like all
the designs are done by me yeah and uh
yeah I hope people like it so check out
nonsense it's uh I'm gonna be and we're
gonna be doing this thing where we
release a new design every month okay
like one new design a month because I
thought like originally I was like
should I do like the usual thing where
it's like oh I drop you know like a
collection yeah a collection of the
collection but I was like no I'm selling
it to people on the internet and the
people on the internet have the [ __ ]
attention span of a goldfish somewhere
let's just like keep bringing stuff out
yeah yeah so keep the drip dripping
exactly keep it keep that tap just
slightly open so that the water's just
constantly drooping you know rather than
keeping it closed and then suddenly
being like here you go you know so yeah
that's the that's the plans for it
obviously I'm not like you know [ __ ]
quitting anything else this is just like
another thing I'm doing on the side so
hey if you like it then uh check it out
I guess and then hopefully pre-orders
will start soon was there anything that
was uh surprisingly Difficult about
making your own clothing brands yeah
like well for one like you know
everything's designed by me but like I
can't do like graphic design yeah well
you know like I can't do like logo
design and stuff like that right so like
even just coming up with like you know
just like the font and stuff like that
for nonsense and like uh I don't know if
the logo is anywhere but like yeah like
you know just something like that right
yeah even just coming up with like that
font took me like two months well that's
why graphic designers are like job
I basically just described what a
graphic designer is damn this [ __ ] hard
job for this yeah right because like you
know I'm not used to that with like
video creating right yeah like usually
it's like nine times out of ten I think
of an idea and then I try and make it
work and then whatever I have you know I
have to work with right especially with
the kind of content I make so it's like
you know even if it's not like perfect
perfect yeah I have to get something out
there right otherwise I won't you know
I'll have the [ __ ] upload schedule of
you know 2015 gaunt essentially yeah
yeah so it's like but like with this
I have to like really be careful with it
because I don't want to get a design out
there and it just looks like [ __ ] yeah
you know because it's like my brand is
on the line essentially how many fonts
did you have to go through
uh like
well I mean for one like the the actual
the official font for the brand is
completely custom yeah so I had to get
like a like a typographer not a not a
graphic designer a typographer I have to
find a typographer to be like and like a
font specialist to be like here's the
brand here's what the brand is about
here's the kind of designs I want yeah
uh can you come up with just like a
shitload of fonts yeah and we literally
went through about 100 fonts and just
decided that's what we want because the
thing about fonts is that it's something
that like most people don't really
appreciate or think about until you have
to choose one like I remember like just
having to choose one just to use for
more like my YouTube videos or just yeah
right a logo or something I'm just like
where the [ __ ] do I even start and then
you go through like the Photoshop like
fun and you like realize that's just
calibri in it
just like the aerial yeah yeah and then
you talk to Graphics yeah yeah and then
you talk to graphic designers and
they're just like they're just like
built different they see a font and they
can like name the font yeah like they
can name the font they can name like the
[Music]
so like I I got like a like you know
working with like a typographer and
everything like I gained like a whole
new appreciation for like graphic design
and typography because like yeah that
shit's hard as [ __ ] and I can see why
you know like in the case with like this
for example like just changing this
spacing the kerning between each of the
letters yeah makes like a completely
different design yeah and you wouldn't
think otherwise though when you make
like a YouTube thumbnail right yeah like
yeah just [ __ ] put the font there and
you're good right right kind of thing so
it's like it made me appreciate like
subtle design yeah if anything and like
you know because I'm kind of going with
like kind of a combination between like
street wear but also loungewear right so
like you could wear this like outside of
course and you know be great but you can
also it's comfortable enough where you
can wear it inside yeah as well so for
for you for you weebs out there that
don't go outside you can still wear it
this is like the longest trash taste ad
we've ever done
yeah no because like you know it's
talking about like fonts and having to
choose fonts and just like being thrown
into a world that you just don't
understand sometimes that yeah you never
knew that you know there was this much
thought into it like I remember like
recently uh this is like going off on a
tangent but I remember recently I've
just got like
had like a binge not really a binge but
just like had my recommended taken over
by these really weird keyboard ASMR
videos I don't know I don't know if you
guys know what I'm talking about I think
I've seen a couple of them
because because uh because how uh how
how like how I basically discovered it
was just this random keyboard video
right and I was just like why is why is
there a keyboard video of just someone
typing on my timeline it's like I click
on it just just uh because I think that
I think the video title was just listen
to the sound of this keyboard or
something right right and it's just like
him like oh or like him or her like just
pressing the keys right and just and the
title was just listen to the space bar
right and it's pressing the keys right
and then he goes to the space bar
and it just sounded like a space bar I
was like it's just a space bar and then
I go to the comments section to be like
what what's what's going on and all of
the comments were just like I was I was
having a nice time until you press the
space bar and then I vomited and it was
just like the vomit emote or something
like that and I was just I've never been
put into a world that I just did not
understand well I mean like I I kind of
felt that when uh I think it was Conor
ride who got like I think one of your
fans made like a custom keyboard yeah
yeah yeah yeah but then they also you
know with the custom cable which looked
sick as [ __ ] there was also this like
other smaller keyboard where you could
test out oh that was gone oh that was
gone it was like it was like a smaller
keyboard where you could test out all
the different types of keys yeah yeah
and like Hammers and I'm just like
what's the difference
like I touched all of them and I was
like half of these sound the [ __ ]
thing I think I think they as someone
who's like using the one of the
expensive keyboards because I don't
think it was given to me I would never
have gone out my way and
[Applause]
now I get it because I use it yeah
before I didn't understand what the
difference was yeah right but I really
like the smoothness and like the subtle
clicks yeah now that I've watched it
it's a very slight click but it's really
nice yeah now that I'm like like 20
keyboard videos down I kind of get it
there's like a nice there's like it's
it's like the thunk sound yeah there's
it's the thong sound where it's zero or
have you just been conditioned maybe
I've just been conditioned I feel like
I'm I'm one of you Cherry MX brand
switches can suck my dick there you go
uh welcome keyboard enthusiasts yeah I'm
like the Cherry switches I can actually
tell they [ __ ] suck now I used to
have it wait listen like why why why it
sounds like like a car crashing every
time you [ __ ] press it in it's so
goddamn loud Oh you mean like the clicky
one super super clicky okay [ __ ] those
ones they what like I had one in my old
office in the UK and since I went back
to the UK it's probably like charity
Brown MX switches they're like the
cheese I think it's like the Cherry blue
yeah yeah yeah
the gatrian ones the gatron is like
gatron's where is that I've got the
gatron Black Ink one oh that's a good
one it's like oh it's [ __ ] good yeah
it's [ __ ] good dude yeah I really
like the gatron like milk yellow I
believe it's it's literally called milky
something milk because it it like it
just has this like nice little thunk to
it and it's nice it's like ASMR right
it's it's so smooth and it's so it's
milky it just sounds like one piece
[Laughter]
like what Lube he used and I was like I
don't need to know what you jacked off
with but yeah I appreciate it yeah so so
to explain like I'm also getting a
custom keyboard made because a fan
message me yeah um but like dude I mean
like I I did pay for the the thing yeah
so he was like oh do you want to get a
keyboard made for you and it's being in
the process of being made and I was just
like yeah sure thinking that he was just
going you know he was just going to send
something that he recommended and he was
like no we're gonna do the entire
process right like what kind of what
kind of keyboard do you want you want
like a hundred percent you want a 75
percent you want to like a fifty percent
I was just like what you are saying
numbers right now it's a keyboard what
are you talking about I have a full
hundred percent keyboard keyboard and I
want every part there yeah why would I
only need 75 of the keyboard yeah I
don't like the number pad and all that
[ __ ] on the side I don't I used to not
care but now that I have a keyboard that
doesn't have a number pad I understand
why it's unnecessary to have it because
I realized I realized until it was gone
I never [ __ ] used to know I know I
know some people like go ham on it and
like
I'm out here I'm totally fine with the
top thing yeah so I just want to save
room yeah I use number pads okay yeah
mostly because when you huh you just
mostly it's it's useful because it's all
the numbers are just close enough yeah I
recognize it's the superior way to
handle numbers it is it is but I I just
like with the amount of like two-factor
authentication I have yeah you know what
I mean like like I'm constantly using
it's not that it is it is it is this
well I definitely had a moment where
like you know I was like you know I
should probably start using the number
pad yeah my old keyboard because it's
there but then I had a moment where I
was just like damn it's so hard to use
with my left hand I was just like doing
this and I'm like oh maybe I should just
take my hand off for now so just do this
why is it not on the left side it'd be
so much easier but then I was like oh I
could just let go of the mouse and
perhaps just do this before you implying
that your right hand was like on your
dick you're like jacking off for you
like let me put in my credit card
details well I'm like jacking up while
like playing run
I mean if you're like an accountant or
something right you got to be pressing
numbers all day then yeah it should make
sense but like I should be used to that
layout as well because it's like you
know every calculator is that layout
right so it's like why is it so hard for
me to use when it's on a keyboard yeah
even though on a calculator it's like
basically second nature yeah like I I I
mean the the reason I like the number
pad is because buying a lot of things
online you've got to enter your credit
card number a lot
um log into your bank account details
how much should you buying yeah it is
like actually beneficial to have that
real estate taken up
um like I don't know like I just have
enough I feel like I use it a lot
because sometimes I need to log into my
bank and you know you when is when
you're entering purely just numbers it's
not like a password that's when the
number pad is useful and like when
you're like entering the numbers on a
line marginally though marginally useful
Mr optimization I thought I thought
you'd be one of me man listen you're
trying to optimize two things at once
how fast can you type stuff in but also
the the space in your desk you know
right right I've got a lot of like [ __ ]
on my desk because you know they've got
like God knows how many I got like two
audio interfaces I got a bunch of other
cables I will I will admit the aesthetic
looks better without them it's the the
aesthetic looks better travels easier
you know trying to put a number you can
put a key like a uh what are they called
a 75 half keyboards yeah 75 yeah 75
keyboard you can put that in the
backpack you can't put a full one in
your bag that's too big why would you
sometimes you're going somewhere maybe
you go into a lan event or something not
that I do anymore but you know what's
the last time you went to a lan event
University yeah I think like it was like
high school for me but also like you
know what if you don't like the the
keyboard on your laptop I get it because
sometimes the laptop keyboards suck and
then you want to bring them with you if
you're going to be like having a remote
setup right packing a full-size keyboard
in the backpack it's pain in the ass
I've never been that desperate I've
never been like every time I've touched
you don't realize you don't realize how
how good having like things smaller and
taking up less space is yeah but like
it's not it's not like my laptop
keyboard isn't so [ __ ] detrimental to
me where I'm like I gotta pack another
keyboard
without a number pad than just use the
laptop keyboard if that makes less sense
more space now you take your more space
I'm having like a remote setup yeah I'm
going to a place I'm going to be
streaming and we're playing games I
don't want to play games on the laptop
uh keyboard controller could bring in
control but some games don't use
controller well then don't play those
games okay well but you're gonna play
these games Joe you're just being
pedantic now for no reason just just
play a game that you can use I'm
not alone I've seen people do this so
many times people don't want to use the
[ __ ] keyboard on the laptop I'm sure
you're not alone but it's done there's
so many people who do this this is I've
never gotten to the point where okay I
have a remote setup right a remote setup
is not like your permanent setup right
yeah but if if I really really really
need a keyboard I just buy like a
[ __ ] five dollar keyboard or
something like that you know like it's
yeah use the laptop one yeah no like I I
like if if I really really wanted like a
remote like a remote setup it's like the
ergonomics you know like using a laptop
keyboard for hours like actually [ __ ]
hurts your wrists using a keyboard for
hours hurts my wrist
that's why I'm trying to use controller
for everything a nice keyboard you know
good ergonomics doesn't doesn't hurt
your wrist yeah you bring the rest as
well yeah yeah
you got the rest too a lot just enough
rest you know my laptop it's amazing
right but I I have to like it's just
there's no support or anything I'm just
putting it I'll just bring the [ __ ]
rest then I just feel like
uh the [ __ ] track pad and [ __ ]
yeah it just doesn't work it doesn't
work I just feel like the inside I've
got someone in the office understands
this point I just think like the whole
point of a laptop is to be portable no
it is like and and like but at that
point you might as well monitor if the
keyboard fits in the bag it's portable
you know what I mean like you can't
bring a p the reason why laptop's
Portables because it's not a giant
[ __ ] case not because the keyboard is
like on him that's like one of the
reasons if I'm whipping it out in a cafe
yeah I'm gonna use the laptop keyboard
right I'm replying it you know it's not
a big deal if I'm streaming or gaming I
want a [ __ ] keyboard but in how are
you like if you're at the point where
you're bringing a portable setup yeah
right like in which so tell tell them
tell me this tell me this hypothetical
situation where you need to set up an
entire stream setup because I'll tell
you it's not just a [ __ ] laptop you
need to bring your if you're bringing
your entire [ __ ] stream set up how
much are you bringing like what do you
want to enter the UK last time I brought
it with me you know you just bring
because if I want to film stuff anyway I
bring a camera anyway the camera has two
uses I can film other stuff do you bring
lights no I don't bring lights you don't
need lights you know you can figure out
lighting it's not a big issue right it's
it's just having a good camera a good
mic and then if you want to play games
or [ __ ] you bring a keyboard on a map
and a mouse you're not going to [ __ ]
use the uh the trackpad right no you're
not going to use
a trackpad is like totally different
than the mouse right right but I mean if
you have a 75 keyboard it's not that big
but then like another thing is like are
you still gaming on the laptop or do you
have like a monitor that you're using as
well uh on the laptop's fine the screen
I have on my laptop is pretty good and
that's not very ergonomic is it
like this desk over there my my other
keyboards here this one's there it's
further away because I have more room
now because the keyboard's not attached
to the thing so I can place the screen
where I want it to so it is ergonomics
does this just sound very pretentious no
this is not this is this is if I wanted
like do it if you want to go portability
why not go for a 50 keyboard then or 50
what or 24. what is the 50 how can you
remove less there is you would be
surprised you would be surprised
smaller keys I already had fat fingers
too I need I need to like why don't you
just invent a keyboard which is just the
space bar and the arrow keys I don't
know who who uses the arrow keys yeah
well if you're playing games okay or
wasd I want all the letters you know
it's like it's
it's half of a pizza box you know what I
mean it's like not even it's tiny it
doesn't take up room and your clothes
are the padding it's it's this isn't
hard why is this so crazy to you it's
like I'm bringing a [ __ ] like pet dog
in my bags is so unbelievable because
because it's just like at that point at
that point where you are not at that
point where you're bringing a streaming
setup a number pad is not that much more
surface area okay but what I'm saying is
like that's just unnecessary like in
general like uh in any keyboard setup
keyboard in your like check-in well
technically if you get a 50 keyboard
you're removing unnecessary keys right
you know you know that's that's the
entire life
it's called a preference Connor it's
called a preference
I would argue right the reason why 75 is
no different from the 100 because you
don't lose anything right you have you
just have numbers twice I don't need
numbers twice I see numbers once this is
not why is this like you're saying like
removing the second numpad is not equal
to being like get rid of half of the
alphabet this is not the [ __ ] same at
all why I can't believe this is an
argument you're making
imagine in the hotel you're stuck for a
week yeah yeah you wanted you want the
TV screen to be your second monitor yeah
leave your laptop there and you can sit
at your bed with your wireless 75 yeah
every every Hotel every Airbnb I do not
pack a keyboard wherever I go no that's
fine but why are you clowning on me this
is not like a clown thing to do this is
a normal sounds incredibly pretentious
and tedious how is it pretentious what
because let me just get my 75 because
because everyone works differently I
can't go to a Starbucks and work like
that's not I I'd be like why is it so
pretentious gone you have to go to a
Starbucks to type you know what I mean
like work from home
like like I don't see how this is
potential I'm losing my mind it's the
way that you're framing it as like this
is the superior way to type this is the
only keyboard that works
number pads irrelevant unnecessary
all I'm saying is you preference I I
like
I use it enough and optionally for me to
be able to justify that it is a
convenience for me all right I like how
did this get to me being clowned on for
bringing keyboards how did this get
trash days baby that's not that's not
the reason you were clowning on me God
the reason you were trying to clown on
me is because I brought keyboard places
because it's funny
it's it's it's it's a lot okay it's it's
a lot I'm just like there's ah
I understand it's a preference you know
I understand it is a preference that you
want to bring your keyboard have you
never thought like when you're like
trying to play games like you're like
why are my hands so [ __ ] close to the
screen no I've I've because here's the
thing like I don't really I'm not a
gamer yeah
right right so why don't you just say
that in the first place instead of
pretending like you were I never pretend
like because because I told you what I'm
using the keyboard for and then you're
like no no that doesn't exist
I also have a portable streaming setup
but I just don't need it I don't need a
keyboard I don't think to myself I am I
I am a carthus Mane in League of Legends
I have a one percent keyboard it's the r
key that's it okay that's you know like
yeah I just I like if I need to game
while I'm out and about I just bring a
[ __ ] controller and just play games
that use a controller yeah but like what
if someone's like oh dude no you've
arranged a a game with someone the game
doesn't have controller then I'll use
the keyboard I'm not gonna [ __ ] have
a hissy fit over and be like where's my
75 percent I wouldn't have a hissy fix I
would have brought it [ __ ] with me so
they wouldn't have been yeah but even
what if you didn't I always bring it
with me no it's not happening and if
it's just a waste of space it's not a
waste of space it's it's thin it's small
how is the keyboard a waste of space
what
I just feel like you guys are just being
pedantic yeah because it's funny
I mean I I feel like I feel like the
argument is are you a gamer are you not
a gamer you know
100 games you know I want to write a lot
of emails and stuff to the point of like
if I'm if I'm doing a lot of work you
know I'm typing for a few hours like
yeah I'm just gonna bring my own I just
it's because like for me it's like I I
will be so much less efficient using the
laptop long so I just won't be
comfortable
um
no I mean I'm I'm okay that's that is
just that is just purely just you
looking for any like I don't know like
because I'm the scripter here I I
actually write more than you Connor yeah
actually he's right more than you it's
the same like because you work one way
everyone must work the same way and
you've re like like so if someone writes
a lot they're the ones that we should
ask like okay tell me about keyboard
ergonomics and how well no that's not I
I I I are you saying that you can't
write as efficiently if you don't have
the right keyboard and everything how do
you function how did you function before
like the 75 keyboards got popularized
you know because it was writing with I'm
not doing wing dings I'm not right with
a [ __ ] number pad can't what you want
this is nothing to do with the 75 now
what are you talking about and now we're
talking about the difference between
laptop and keyboards yeah I I am I'm
just I'm just like if also you know your
laptop doesn't have a number pad right
yeah I know
like
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
it doesn't matter
listen how you work is like totally up
to you right if you if you are a person
who gets really agitated by a certain
way and that's just like that bugs you
yeah I think that's just that's up to
you could you just knuckle down
sometimes and get on with it yeah you
can but I mean at the end of the day
it's if you're doing something creative
and it's something that you're Your Own
Boss with you're probably gonna work as
much as you want yeah and sometimes
Comfort is a factor in that and for me
that's what I need yeah but you're
gaming you're right if I am working
though as well it's the same thing I
just don't want to use it right right
that was the most long-winded dumbass
argument we've ever had on trash days
I just felt like I explained a very
valid point and then I got I got jumped
on it
totally a reasonable Behavior to to not
want to use that okay okay because
because like maybe it's because I don't
have a custom keyboard yet but like I
don't fully understand I don't take my
main keyboard I take some like 50 ones
I just needed one that's further away
and that I can set up to be more like
wait so you don't even take your your
good
optimize custom keyboard not like the
super expensive one no I just take like
one that I do so you have several
keyboards yeah yeah well I learned my
lesson because what my keyboard broke
one time I couldn't do any work or
couldn't stream or anything right and I
you know I was [ __ ] and I was like
well this seems dumb so now I just
bought I have a spare keyboard
yeah because like it's a good idea yeah
if your entire job revolves around doing
like being able to use this one device
yeah you should probably have backups of
everything that could possibly break
that's fair enough but I don't think
I've ever broken a keyboard before
keyboards all the time you know maybe
you've had a key that was acting up that
was pissing you off or yeah maybe the
yeah yeah yeah it happens all the time
yeah keyboards are like [ __ ] frail
things yeah yeah because to me like
houses break all the time I've got like
three backup mouses yeah because like
maybe like this this comes down to the
conversation like me and Tech like even
though I'm an engineer I'm I don't like
I just need a job to be done you know
what I mean I don't really care about
Aesthetics or like right stuff too much
I just like
Aesthetics I don't care about that you
don't well it's just about it's about
like
preference of like how I like it to work
yeah you know yeah because like for
example like headphones for example I
literally don't like I I my preference
with headphones is to buy like the
cheapest headphones I can possibly right
I'm the opposite with headphones yeah
yeah yeah because I I know people are
like really really really
India right in here yeah you don't use
headphones like clamshell headphones you
mean those are headphones right yeah oh
sorry earphones yeah I only use
earphones for like running yeah yeah I
don't I prefer to use headphones every
other time I don't like yeah to me like
headphones I don't know why
um I think it might be because I have
like Jaw problems or something like if I
wear headphones for too long it just
like really starts to put pressure on my
drone stuff but like yeah with with
earphones and like this is going above
protect but like there are certain
things like earphones sunglasses where I
try to buy the cheapest possible because
I've gone through too many or you know
like just sometimes you buy like you I I
remember buying like at the end of every
day you're like track all right next one
no yeah because like sometimes I
misplaced them or something but
especially with sunglasses right yeah
it's so it's so easy to misplace
sunglasses especially because you wear
them out and sometimes utilize you don't
always have your case on you or
sometimes you you know you take it you
don't have a bag or anything you take
them off you like clip them on your
shirt and they just fall off sometimes
like I've I've had that happen too many
times and with earphones sometimes you
just get sometimes you replace them
misplaced them or you like forget that
they're in your jean Pockets or
something
um so so the headphones kind of make you
uncomfortable because they're like put
pressure on your head yeah yeah it's the
same thing for me and the keyboard and
the wrist though it just hurts my wrist
if I if I if I have to use that flat
thing for ages right because your wrist
is like why why are we doing this also I
I'm like paranoid about getting any
wrist injuries or carpal tunnels yes you
know I want to get well you gain way
more than that yeah
I I'm very cautious about like wrist
injuries so I I want the most ergonomic
setup once again like those like wrist
guard things then but I've seen a couple
streams yeah I mean that's that's they
normally have that on when it's too late
and they've already like done I know
some people who have it on like to
actually just prevent it I mean if you
have a good setup you shouldn't need
that yeah but you know even people with
good setups can sometimes you know game
a little too hard yeah but like
headphones like for me it's like I can't
have the in-ear ones because any every
single in your headphones for some
reason wants to like excavate your ear
yeah and get really in there yeah yeah
and that hurts the [ __ ] out of my ears
oh so I can't use those yeah it's
probably because you don't have like the
right size buds right yeah I have one
that comes with a bunch of replaceable
ones but even then like airpods are
unironically are the ones that I like
the most because they don't really go in
your ear much yeah they kind of like sit
on top of it that's what I like them
most but I don't use apple so I don't
have them
um and that's why I use it like the
ovary ones also the sounds way nicer I
only use the over ear ones if it's like
in the winter because it also like keeps
my head warm but like in the summer here
especially I'm just like nope headphones
go away I should always use them yeah
yeah I do like I've seen you like
walking in like the Japanese some with
headphones on I'm like bro that looks
bad that is dedication yeah that's
dedicated listening that's the Comfort I
mean you your headphones have taken a
[ __ ] beating it's like it's like I
remember seeing it just falling apart
it's like falling apart man like holy
[ __ ]
what's because it's because I'm waiting
for the right now I'm using the Sony WX
um 1003 the worst naming system of all
time yeah yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
sort of string of numbers and letters
and then like the the next one the fours
I I there isn't really a significant
upgrade yeah and I'm hoping the fives
when they ever come out which I don't
even know if they will I'm like a decent
upgraded I'm kind of in that weird spot
where it's like they're they're like
broken and they're not working properly
yeah but but like because they're like
you know 300 headphones yeah I want them
to last like five years yeah of course
of course so if I buy the the fours now
and then the fives come out and they're
like the most best upgrades and you can
hear God through them yeah I'm gonna be
really pissed off that I bought these
fours yeah and I just didn't wait a few
months actually but I don't know I don't
even know if it's coming out I don't
even know they don't even answer
anything so I'm just waiting kind of
hoping you're waiting for something it
works definitely the one side is
completely broken so it keeps falling
out yeah [ __ ]
I thought about it this episode is
sponsored by Honey the easy way to save
When shopping on your iPhone or computer
Joey how do you feel about shopping
online I feel positively I feel it's the
only way the zoom is short you know one
thing by shopping online how many times
has a promo code just taunted you when
you're at the checkout I just don't want
to be missing out on Deal Lads honey is
the free shopping tool that scales the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your cart let me
just tell you how it works I'll tell you
exactly how it is all right imagine
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites all right okay when you go to the
checkout the honey button appears and
all you have to do is a click apply
coupons wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll just watch the prices job
you know guys now that we're in England
we gotta buy plenty of tea and thanks to
honey I saved 20 pounds I'm basically
robbing from the queen herself so if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free deals
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting us the
boys and get honey for free at
joinhoney.com trash taste let's jump
honey.com trash taste it's win-win guys
it's win-win back to the episode okay
you're the gamer right you talked about
keyboards all right 144 Hertz monitors
all right okay if you if you genuinely
think there's no difference
is there a point if you don't play FPS
because I genuinely like i j because we
have we have uh we have them in the
office I've never used them I notice it
more with FPS games but like even normal
games that that are not like locked to
60 look way better in 144. I think
that's a problem I only play games that
are locked to 60. because you're on the
switch Yeah right if you actually game
on your PC 144 Hertz is way it looks way
better than I don't know I'd rather have
144 Hertz than like a more like higher
resolution right it's way nicer and
smoother and it looks good I don't know
why resolutions milky after like 2K I
can't [ __ ] tell the difference like I
I I I I I I especially barely look any
different from 2K to me yeah I feel way
more different from 60 to 120 hertz 144
Hertz yeah because I feel the difference
with FPS I just don't play FPS you know
so I was just like what other game types
would really like really make me feel
the difference because I've already
craft any any game where you're you know
you're moving around you're controlling
a character moving Minecraft's probably
the only one where I've probably like
somewhat slightly seen it right you
might notice it's more fluid it looks
good you'll notice when you go back that
it's like not quite the same it's not
bad it's not like you know if if you you
haven't got a lot of money right and
you're choosing between like a better PC
or like a monitor that makes you like
come instantly yeah just get a better PC
get better parts or something yeah right
like it's kind of like the cherry on top
but there's no point buying a monster PC
if you're then not also going to get a
good monitor right right because you're
you're basically buying like an engine
with a car that can't fit it like it's
like okay well I mean it's a point you
know a lot of people will have like
3080s and still use 60 FPS monitors and
I'm like you know
you've put like rockets on a scooter
it's like it's just too much yeah like
you're overpowering it I don't know I
mean I game a lot so I guess I yeah I
mean I mean I I am that guy who has a
3080 and uh and he's a 60 FPS but like
that's because it's like a [ __ ]
monster to render when I'm editing yeah
that's the only other like yeah yeah if
you're not gaming if you're doing I
definitely use it like that more than
the gaming yeah like like I've
definitely not noticed anything massive
massive difference rendering and editing
like that's like I I don't I don't need
60 FPS if you're streaming it's also
very good yeah yeah it is uh the Nvidia
cards have dedicated video chips that
are completely separate to the gaming
yeah so you can you can game and stream
at the same time and it doesn't affect
the performance sure but it does a
little bit no that's because of how
other things going on what do you think
about so so do you care about the
keyboard thonk then like I mean the ASMR
yes I do I mean I I like what I have
right now I maybe I should we don't can
remind me to record something
I'm on the fence right now because I'm
gonna be getting my custom keyboard
within like a few months so maybe I'm
gonna be like man Conor was right this
entire time
yeah yeah yeah because like I remember
going on this video and just looking at
the comment section and I'm just like
I've seen less horny comments on PornHub
comments you know like my God like you
I've I literally feel like everyone is
coming from like the sound of these keys
and I'm just like yeah that's a nice
dining key I guess it's weird because
it's like it feels like almost like
Play-Doh at first because you're so used
to the really harsh clicks yeah yeah the
ones it feels like oh it's really like
squishy and so wet yeah but then after a
while you get used to it you're like oh
no this is actually a really fun yeah
the clicks are really solid yeah but
they're not like in your [ __ ] face
it's not like it's screaming hey you
just clicked hey hey you just clicked it
do you want to be that [ __ ] on
Discord he's like yeah because I
remember when mechanical keyboards got
popularized and that was like the
popular key because it was like it was
like everyone bought the 30 uh
mechanical keyboard on Amazon because
they thought mechanical equaled good
when in fact I just can't get over like
you describing like the sound of these
keys and you know it just sounds like
you know hearing the experience of
someone going on a drug I've never been
on you know it's just like At first it's
like really wet but then I want to get
used to it it gets like really firm and
it's like oh
yeah
because when when I was picking the keys
because like uh like I'll I'll take a
picture and send a Gmail but like I have
like a whole [ __ ] like it's a
keyboard yeah it's a test it's a square
of just keys of different keys and I
have and like it's it's bad with someone
with ADHD because it's just like you
just like constantly clicking it and
you're just like oh this this is a fun
toy oh this is a fun toy this is it's
like fidget Spinner's got nothing on
this and then you have to like click one
and then you have to choose one key from
like a hundred yeah I'm like at some
points like Keys just like meld together
and they're like different like the
different like lubiness of keys and like
I didn't know I didn't know luminous
like matted with keyboard Keys like I'm
just like okay at which point I'm like
I'm get it it's it's like a hobby right
it's it's it's it's a it's a hobby kind
of object right because you have to
really be really into it to really care
about it this much
yeah a key file right right which one
does it get like too much where yeah
where it's no too much is it never too
much never too much all right I'm
waiting I'm waiting I'm waiting for my
first time this is why we're gonna have
flying cars they're the ones in this
yeah yeah yeah I I I I've someone told
me on stream yesterday I was like they
are completely unrelated but you said
ADHD so it came from my mind
um I was like no no I checked because
Chad was accusing me of having ADHD and
I said no I don't know what I was like I
can like I can focus on things I get
really fixated yeah and they're like you
know focusing too much is a sign of ADHD
right and I was like what yeah it
apparently it is yeah so so I was like
wait what if I if I concentrate too much
on things you have ADHD but if I don't
concentrate enough I've had HD2 and I'm
like wait wait but then wait hold up
what is it what does that mean what is
it how does it work it's just I don't
know it's like you can't be on too far
off the either side of the spectrum yeah
yeah because then you have a problem
because it isn't specify that you can't
pay attention it's attention
who's making these rules up huh
people who are more informed uh than us
you know I was like oh damn these people
coming up with these these definitions
that's crazy it's usually the person
that says you have ADHD yeah like
officially how do you test if someone
concentrates too much how do you I'm
genuinely curious it's nice to be like
you can't control yourself and you
realize that oh [ __ ] it's like oh you're
gonna question something oh yeah yeah so
you get obsessed it's kind of repeat
that yeah it is but at the same time
it's like you can't control it but I
feel there's a lot of people like in
just this internet age that you know
because we're so [ __ ] over sensitized
and just overwhelmed with all this
[ __ ] information right all at the
same time right there are so many people
who are just like oh there's so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] to do on the internet do I
have ADHD I'm like no you're just on the
internet this is also I wonder I'm like
I don't think like I have a problem I
think there's just so much [ __ ] that's
being shoved in my face yeah that's what
it is but that's why like I reckon
there's probably I mean like you have
ADHD how does it feel I mean I got it is
weird right because the the reason I I
only like recently got diagnosed with
ADHD and it was just like the most aha
moment of my life like of course I do
you know it's like oh that's what that
was because like you know especially
like growing up in Asian culture mental
health and mental conditions are very
like it's like literally that Meme image
of just don't be sad like yeah yeah
cutting the water yeah cutting cutting
the water of like don't be sad don't be
sad so I I remember like because I have
this like such a vivid memory in school
right of uh I knew someone in school who
got diagnosed with ADHD and they got
like some like advantage or something in
that in like a test that we were taking
right I go like extra time or something
and then you remember like describing
like what he what his experience of ADHD
was and I was just like what a [ __ ]
liar I he he like what a [ __ ] liar I
do that and he's getting some free time
on an exam what the [ __ ] and it's just
like it was like was like it just didn't
it just for some reason it just never
[ __ ] occurred to me that uh
unfortunately I had the same symptoms
because I was raised not not even raised
but like a lot of people in my culture
and the environment I grew up with
um it was just we it was put in our
minds that you know mental health just
wasn't really like it was either like a
very very serious thing or it just like
was just didn't exist and you've just
got to get on with it there's no such
thing as a mild symptom yeah yeah yeah
like you either had it or you don't know
so what made you think oh I should go
and see if I have it like what was the
Turning Point what like what so this can
be awful
um enough comments on trash taste I am
actually wait why did you like fidgeting
with things huh because you were
fidgeting with things honestly seeing
myself on camera I'm just like damn man
I do that [ __ ] what yeah like hey
because like obviously I've never been
on camera and especially with me yeah
being on camera documented so much on
trash taste I'm like damn I do a lot of
people analyze yeah yeah
habits because you're looking at
yourself through the third person
um and then also you know there's
there's always going to be comments that
are like psychoanalyzing and over
analyzing stuff yeah like we'll say some
really wild yeah yeah yeah but then like
what I I saw some comments that are just
like [ __ ] they kind of make sense and
then they Google it uh Google what they
say I'm like damn that doesn't look like
it's uh that doesn't look like it's just
someone talking out their ass and then
like the final straw was uh meeting
someone here who has ADHD and they
describe their symptoms I'm like [ __ ]
okay I need I need to go get diagnosed
right I need to go get checked out
um and yeah it was thanks to trash taste
I guess and thanks to random Youtube
comments well done guys you uh you're
like it's like the one time in the world
where you guys were actually correct
with your diagnosis you weren't just a
bunch of like Reddit armchair
psychologists and Wild Ones yeah yeah
it's in Wild diagnosis yeah I do I I
have as a views of trash
that's not an excuse to psychoanalyze
all of us okay a broken clock is right
two times you know guys
I remember my uh my
I was growing up they everyone was like
convinced I'd like dyslexia yeah and
like I was like no I don't think I do
because I don't really have from reading
the word I just really [ __ ] hate
doing it right but because they would
describe the symptoms to me as like a uh
you know when I was like 10 or something
so just give some backstory to this uh I
you know I went to a Welsh school I
didn't like reading I liked gaming I was
probably my parents my parents probably
wish that nobody'd ever introduced me to
gaming yeah but I I I was introduced to
gaming very very young right yeah
talking like four five six I found out
about video games yeah I became like
obsessed and I read the games I I mean I
I've said this before I beat all of one
of the first games I ever played with
Pokemon Gold in French and I beat the
whole game in French I don't know how
even though you don't know any french
yeah this must have been literally the
birth of me bashing my head against the
wall to figure out yeah video games yeah
not reading so I've been doing this
since like a young age not I I never
really like read stuff I just kind of
did it this is probably like sounds very
like monkey-esque already and not you
know not very well it's very like a like
a primeval like yeah it is
so and I went to a Welsh school so I
didn't really
um read English like ever we learned
everything in Welsh I spoke in Welsh in
school so I never read English like ever
the only thing I'd ever read is like we
go to the store I can I can read the I
would just read the [ __ ] right yeah
whatever like but like like when I would
be quizzed on like how to spell [ __ ] I
like wouldn't know they'd be like spell
said I'd be like oh yeah just said Zed
in it said
yeah so when we started learning English
more and I was like yeah I just don't
don't read books ever yeah and they're
like what you didn't read books my
parents were like yeah we tried to we
tried to break him really but he keeps
playing those goddamn video games
as much Pro my parents tried their
goddamn hardest to get me to read it was
just not gonna happen like I was just I
had absolutely zero interest in it yeah
so I was so so bad at English but like
they knew I was very competent all other
subjects like I was I was very like you
know maths and Science and all that
really really high marks like I was you
know I mean I got like like a star and
[ __ ] and maths and all that so the
highest grade you can get went did
engineering all that there's no problem
with like I wasn't like like bad at
learning yeah it was just I just hated
this one subject right but they were
convinced they were like what what if
he's Compton and other stuff he just
must have some uh dyslexia or something
right and they would tell me what the
symptoms were yeah and it was so
annoying because a kid this is where I
started learning where adults like [ __ ]
with you as a kid yeah they would like
try and spoon feed me the answers to
like set to like dyslexia right I would
like to try and tell me I had symptoms
that I didn't have until I get you to
agree to it just because they wanted to
have like that like so they can tick it
off it's like oh we've figured it out
yeah we sort them out and then whenever
I have an issues they'll be like oh
don't worry we don't have to put him
work he's just dyslexic yeah this is
where you like I get it because the
teachers they want an answer they want
to read they want a solution right they
want to know why and I can understand
everyone wants a reason why but like
unfortunately mental health and [ __ ]
like that and yeah and and learning is
like the most complicated [ __ ] known to
men and there is never ever just a one
solution that fits all yeah like just
because somebody sucks on something it
doesn't mean there's an inherent problem
so I would like talk to my teachers and
stuff and yeah and I remember talking to
my English teacher and she like made me
like stay after class and she talked to
me and she'd be like so you can you can
read these words right and I was like
yeah I can read them and she's like they
don't look like messed up or jumbled at
all and I was like and I was like no not
really and then she was like sometimes
the words are hard to read I'm like yeah
I don't know the word sometimes I don't
really know it so it's kind of hard to
read because English is kind of funny
and the pronunciation is weird and then
so she was like okay okay so then
another teacher came in a few weeks
later and started asked me more
questions about dyslexia and stuff and I
was like no no I I the words are not
[ __ ] jumbled okay I've seen the
movies they don't [ __ ] do that I know
that's not how it works but I'm like
yeah I I do not have a problem I can see
all the letters in order they do not
move I know what I'm reading I am just
[ __ ] at this subject and I don't like it
because they start shaking your body
like what about now yeah yeah
it was literally like I had I'm thank
God I wasn't like uh I wasn't a kid they
were just like I feel bad because like
kids are so easily like pushed into
saying yes or no yeah I'm so glad I was
a stubborn [ __ ] from like a young age
where I was like no the words are not
jumbled I don't have a problem reading
the word I just just hate this shitty
subject yeah I hate English yeah and
they were like no no no no no you have
to be you have to be so you have to have
a disability you must be you must be
yeah I'm very glad that Iris I don't
know where I got the stubbornness from
yeah I was like because I I remember
like I it was really annoying and they
kept insisting I had it yeah no no
I do not have this I have no problem
reading Of Mice and Men I just don't
like it I'd rather watch the movie
they're like trying to just like
brainwash you yeah okay so this is what
I'm realizing and I understand now why
like you know this whole discussion
about diagnosing kids is like yeah I get
why it's like a a touchy subject and
some parents are like my kids you can't
diagnose them and then you know some
people are so quick to jump to it it's a
really uncomfortable subject and kind of
touchy because yeah the kids often can't
like I was a kid I couldn't fully
Express that you know I can't just be
like listen I didn't really connect with
the subject I don't like it yeah they
can't fit for themselves right yeah I
can't really fully explain why I don't
want to why I don't engage with this
yeah but they you know they're just like
well they're like no we're the adults we
know more than you right yeah yeah yeah
so it's kind of a it's weird man and I
think that's why like when you get
parents that are super passionate about
it and stuff and then there's also the
thing of like
some parents don't want to
get their kids diagnosed with things
because they don't want to like be like
my kid has a problem or has something
right my parents didn't really give a
[ __ ] they were like if he's got it he's
got it whatever yeah just deal with it
but yeah yeah because I I think with how
mental health is now it's just like it
feels like at least it feels like if
you're diagnosed with something then
then the kind of feeling is oh there's
something wrong with me obviously yeah
yeah you know there's something there's
something broken with me because like uh
like with me and ADHD for example like I
I didn't realize that I was abnormal you
know because I would have I would I
would do all these things to basically
basically be able to like seem like I
was able to function you know and I I'd
only learned recently that that was like
my coping mechanisms for like my what it
was like my how my brain works you know
yeah I'd figured out ways to live with
it
um and I thought everyone had to do that
you know that's that's just what I
thought and like especially like after
being diagnosed it hasn't like changed
my life or anything like that it's like
the biggest thing that it's done for me
is like it's just helped me understand
myself and I think that's just I think
that's like the most valuable thing yeah
right definitely it's just like make
sense of things that you were like why
why am I like yeah yeah exactly because
it's just helped me like deal with it
even more because I I just remembered
because it wasn't it wasn't just the
YouTube comments as well I remember
specifically seeing this one YouTube
video and that was that was like the
last straw where I was like where what
am I diagnosed no no where it was like
where it was like what ADHD feels like
and someone like someone like edited a
video of their day and like edited it in
a way to like to like show how they
perceive the world yeah how they
perceived the world and it was like such
a one for one copy of how I see the
world I was just like oh my God so like
that was like the aha moment because I
think I think that was one one scene in
particular because uh he was going about
his day and uh he was like being scolded
uh by his teacher or his mom or
something and and uh he was like
fidgeting right he was fidgeting and uh
and he would get told off for that for
him because his mom always teacher I
can't remember who was exactly but he
was just they were just like can you
concentrate please I'm trying to tell
you something serious yeah and you're
doing something else and I'm just like
and he said oh but it helps me to
concentrate and I'm just like that's
been my entire life that's been if like
I need to fidget with something in order
to concentrate and if I don't I just
lose like my trailer thoughts or
something right it's just like me yeah
yeah I was just like holy [ __ ] maybe
maybe I should [ __ ] go in and get
this so how do they because I've always
been curious like when you go see a
doctor right and you want to like you
know figure out if you are actually
diagnosed with it how does the doctor
like check that well is that like a test
it just puts like a Ruby's Cube on the
table he's like I'll be back in 15
minutes let's
put fidget spinner
yeah
curious like you know how does the
doctor like kind of determine whether
you actually have ADHD or if it's just
like something similar to that that's
not necessarily ADHD right yeah I mean
uh at the moment I'm at like I'm still
like processing and learning and
learning through it because at the
moment at the beginning they uh take you
when they do like this uh this just uh
it's it's a survey at first so it's like
it's like the first test
um but then afterwards if you tick
enough boxes to be like okay there's
there's you know there's there's a
chance then you go into the psychologist
and you know they ask you like a bunch
of questions for me at least I don't
know because like uh another friend in
England just recently got diagnosed with
ADHD as well and I think in England they
have a different kind of process yeah
yes I think it's different to every
country uh in England I believe there's
like a you have to go to like a group
session as well or something like that
it's different in every country but for
me it was more just a one-on-one talk
with uh with my you know with the
psychology psychologist where they just
ask me like very detailed questions
about my experiences how I perceive
events and like I can't remember
everything because there was like a lot
of [ __ ] questions yeah it was kind of
it was basically like a therapy session
where she's like so so tell me about
this week talking about this tell me
about that
um and yeah I mean uh ever since being
diagnosed I've like like I said my life
hasn't changed that much I just know now
it's like written in paper that's uh
no no I I I got the plaque of just like
his
how your brain works and here's why you
your brain does this [ __ ] yeah and like
ever since known that I'm like ah that
makes sense now I have like a word to
put to how I felt for a lot of My Life
um and yeah that's it like like that's
the thing I feel a lot of people uh a
lot of people maybe have you know maybe
have different different conditions or
different mental conditions that they've
just never really thought about because
Like Me Maybe you found a way to cope
with it day to day you know because Like
Me Maybe you thought that hey maybe
everyone's like this and you've just
found a way to live normally because uh
because you've grown up uh you've grown
up in an environment where you just need
to like just get on with it basically
and a lot of a lot of the times like not
every mental condition is just like on
the extreme end sometimes it's like
really really subtle yeah but if you've
ever like had a thought that maybe maybe
I do have this or maybe I do have that I
think it might be worth just talking to
someone not like not to like have a like
a life-changing aha moment but just
learning more about yourself I feel like
is the most valuable thing that someone
can someone can do yeah and uh doesn't
mean that doesn't mean that there's
necessarily anything wrong with you you
know I think people more people would
probably go if it was like easier to get
seen yeah yeah definitely most
definitely right it's like yeah yeah got
to be either rich or have a lot of time
on your hands yeah or both or both yeah
to get anything done Health Care wise or
mental health-wise I don't know I know
in the UK it's not too great I know
they're like yeah trying to get better
at it but I know it's not adequate yeah
in the UK it's like the waiting list is
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] like huge yeah
no kidding yeah because
um yeah because I feel like the biggest
problem especially like everywhere but
America I can see is like the access to
Mental Health Care is it's difficult to
sell especially in Asia in Japan dude
it's like oh my God it's half the time
it's just like non-existent yeah yeah
mental health in Japan is the easy car
there is no
it's like go to the pub it could be a
don't think about it I know why you're
sad it's because you're not drunk right
now go to an Izakaya have a couple of
beers you'll be all right and then it's
just no I was like I I was walking home
and I saw a guy just like on the floor
just crying in in Tokyo and I was like
why is like no one no one helping him
like loads of people just walking past
him like why is no one saying like hey
are you okay this is so weird to me I
was like what people are just like man I
wanna don't wanna get involved yeah yeah
they don't they don't that's the thing
they see because you know again
collectivist Society they see one you
know uh Cog that's out of the system and
they're like well that's not our problem
we just gotta keep the call we're just
gonna keep the system moving well the UK
isn't great but I think at least where I
was from if someone was like crying in
the street like everyone would be like
you okay oh yeah yeah I think I'd say
most English-speaking countries they'll
definitely be at least a couple people
be like hey you know yeah all right dude
what's up yeah at least like someone
checking on them yeah exactly and you
know not to say that Japan isn't you
know the [ __ ] Mistress of the world
in that sense right like there's
definitely people I've seen people you
know go up to strangers
I wanted to help but I was like I don't
want this to be an awkward language
barrier situation where you actually
need help and I I'm just like oh hi you
know yeah I felt so sad about that I
couldn't do anything to help this dude
because I was like I don't I don't know
just imagining what situations he could
be going through maybe so [ __ ] sad I
was like what if what if his parents
like just said he couldn't go home or
something I don't know I was like
yeah man yeah I just wanted to add an
addendum to what I said uh if you do
like I I think a big issue nowadays is
as well is like there's a lot of
self-diagnosis yeah like especially I've
seen it on Tick Tock it's the internet
doctors like like they're like I've read
one Google article I am like I you know
I'm like I got this ADHD or I'm like
well it's almost like the uh what's the
word the like collection of uh you know
people kind of I mean so you will but
online they kind of see it's like a
badge of honor yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah people do they're like I'm if I
have XX thing and I have it in my bio
I'm like yeah or you're like immune to
like sometimes like being an [ __ ] or
something yeah yeah like it's just like
it's I don't know I I it sucks because
you don't want to be like man people are
faking it but it's like how are people
faking it I never see it as like a badge
of honor in a way yeah what and even and
you know even if you be proud about it
you can be proud about it and be open
about it yeah exactly is it like don't
be a dick about it you're
self-diagnosing so that you can then go
and brag about it online and it's like
what the [ __ ] yeah
but people actually have to deal with
this [ __ ] yeah yeah I know right
actually it's I mean that whole argument
comes into like well we couldn't afford
to go to a doctor and get actual
diagnosis and it's like yeah but you
probably you still should never diagnose
I don't think anyone ever would
recommend you self-diagnose no no no
especially you'll be completely wrong
especially if something as delicate and
as complicated as mental health like you
like like I said the mind is a
complicated thing and people do weird
[ __ ] A lot of the times and uh you can
you can never know unless you really see
like an expert you know and then it also
sucks as well because then you see an
expert maybe the expert was a [ __ ] of
this job or something you know so
there's always this like [ __ ]
Minefield yeah yeah like counter
arguments have you ever like had a bad
experience with like a doctor or
anything like that yeah I've had doctors
where I'm like yo this thing is actually
like [ __ ] hurting me and then he's
like oh no it's good
I'm like some bad severe pains like no
you're good and then another doctor's
like oh holy [ __ ] man you gotta this is
like you gotta sort this out I've got a
lot of instances where I go to like a
local doctor like a local GM and they'll
be like I'll refer you to a bigger
Hospital yeah after looking at it for
like two seconds and then you go to the
bigger hospital and they're like oh
here's some drugs you can get anywhere
I'm like why did the guy at the local GM
not do that instead of [ __ ] wasting
my time taking me to another bigger
hospital that's way further away yeah to
do the exact same job that he could have
done yeah you know it's only the only
one I've had yeah because especially me
like right now I'm like I think my
biggest 30s like Health thing that I've
that I've found so much is like my jaw
my jaw issue and so I've been like
trying to get someone I've been trying
to find an expert to help me sort it out
so you know I go to uh I go to the
dentist to try and like try and find out
what's wrong with my jaw right and so
like I mean I remember the first time
I've tried to get it sorted out was uh I
remember I went to like several dentists
in the UK and uh one of them said oh do
you still have your wisdom teeth and
they were like and I was like yeah I
still have my wisdom teeth but like
they're not like the spacing in it isn't
like it isn't bad or anything it's not
like hurting me or anything like that
and they're like yeah we recommend you
get that uh we recommend you get that
taken out I was like okay do I that's a
that's a big commitment you know yeah
because you know at the time I was still
a YouTuber
um so you know talk yeah you can't you
can't you can't talk you can't talk so I
like I wanted to make sure that I needed
to go through this procedure uh so I
went to a second dentist for a second
opinion and he was like no definitely
don't take your wisdom teeth out that's
not the issue
um here have this mouth guard and I was
like okay he gave me the mouth but I
didn't like improved it a little bit but
I like the problems still persisted so
uh uh he K I went back to him and he's
like yeah honestly uh maybe you need uh
braces or something uh that's gonna cost
like 30 000 pounds or something I was
like okay
okay let's uh if let's let's be sure I
need to go through this and I guess so
like at this point I'd move to Japan
yeah right and then come to come to
Japan go do the same thing go to the
dentist and they were like you don't
need to take your wisdom teeth out but
maybe just take the top wisdom teeth out
I'm just like I'm getting like a dude
like every dentist I've gone to so far
has given me a different opinion about
what needs to be done so I'm like who do
I listen to yeah another one and it's
like so you only need to remove half
your wisdom teeth just like the top half
just like shave it off yeah yeah yeah
just shave the tall fall you'll be all
right yeah I'm just lying it's it's so
like I I want to get it fixed but I just
it's it's scary because whatever I go
through it's a big commitment obviously
in time and cost and it's it's my body I
want to make sure it's done right
um at the same time everyone know
everyone I say everyone I meet is
telling me different things so I have I
have no [ __ ] clue who to listen to
basically I got like tonsil I just like
I used to get it like every year right
and they were like just remove your
tonsils and I was like
God because I said they say there's a
chance it can like affect your voice
yeah yeah and I was like I'd rather just
be sick once a year and that's like a
lot of pain well you haven't had it in a
while though right no luckily I haven't
had it in a while I don't think I've had
it in Japan yeah exactly but I used to
get it like every year right yeah it's a
pain in the ass I still want my voice to
change so I was like I like my voice
right now it's kind of important to my
job yeah yeah what if I change it
although they say like you have a chance
that the voice will change but it's not
like you're gonna be like hey guys
I'm just like I have learned how to use
my voice yeah for like voice acting like
I I guess you're gonna like relearn it I
don't know how it would feel I I don't
they they just told me there's a chance
it could change slightly
for me it's just not worth it I was like
I'll just be sick every now and then
yeah I'll take the sickness plus light
isn't real it's not an illness it's a
mindset
that's a lifestyle
yeah yeah no I still have my I still
have mine oh dude when you get it
[ __ ] Hood have you ever had it yeah
I've had it no it's horrible yeah it's
[ __ ] horrible your voice your like
throat closes up so much it feels like
it's like you know there's like [ __ ]
squishy toys where you put your finger
in it yeah that's how I imagine your
throat looks like yeah it's horrible
it's so gross that sounds gross yeah
that's not that bad it's just your voice
how do you get it you just like it's
like a virus you pick up or yeah I
believe it's a virus I don't know it's
like an infection on your tonsil oh okay
right it might be viral material or
something I don't know just [ __ ] Too
Many Dicks right
now
yeah now that I'm a Georgia fan I gotta
be careful
you can't be going on anything yeah
don't want to pick up tunnel tonsillitis
for my next block generally I just avoid
going to the hospital or clinic at all
costs I'm like yeah yeah I mean I've
heard I've said this before I just don't
want to go yeah I don't know I'll just
put like dead before I go
that's just like really severe allowing
like a lot of pain yeah right so we kind
of went on like a one-hour tangent from
Joey saying we're gonna get back to
explaining with the title of this video
holy [ __ ]
fashion Joey's like we'll get back to
this we'll get back to this one hour
later
yeah so uh we're gonna be leaving Japan
after this episode for a little bit of
time specifically
two months quote unquote is it two
months and a half months something like
that it doesn't really matter because I
mean you guys aren't gonna know the
exact yeah you're gonna be filming trash
taste in abroad yeah we're going we're
going yeah we're going is this we're the
next Arc is going to be trash taste
abroad basically yeah we're gonna say
goodbye to this studio for now uh
because we're going to be filming in
some of the different countries that
we're going to be in uh I mean obviously
one we can say because we announced it
like couple of episodes ago yeah you
know since if you guys watch the episode
four episodes ago yeah I think where we
announced where we're going to ax by the
way see you guys there yeah uh then
obviously uh you'll know we're gonna be
in La for a while yep so uh yeah we're
filming some episodes in L.A in London
as well yeah we're gonna be because
these boys are going to be coming to the
wedding as well my wedding which by the
time of release of this episode should
have just should have happened should
have already happened yeah yeah yeah so
congrats yeah
this is uh yeah I'll be a married man
IRL by the time this episode comes out
uh
as opposed to YouTube
that's gonna be the old term the guy's
like do you say I do because
I put the fidget spinner down
but yeah like uh so we're gonna be
filming some episodes in London some in
La
um and we're gonna have like a lot more
guests on than we usually would for
trash taste so it's gonna be like a lot
of guests yeah it's gonna be like an
answer so we had like no guests for like
20 episodes yeah yeah we're gonna have a
lot of guests in a row and then
obviously you know some people are gonna
like that some people don't like it but
I think we just wanna we wanna go
somewhere and mix it up and try it yeah
yeah yeah you know if you don't like the
episodes you don't like we'll be back
you know Nothing's Gonna Change don't
worry we have over 100 episodes at this
point yeah you know she doesn't go
anywhere so uh you know thing we want to
do we want to mix it up and we hope that
the change of scenery will look
interesting as well I mean obviously
won't maybe not look as professional but
yeah hopefully it'll uh still be the
same old podcast let's press the fresh
air yeah because because like we've had
we've had so many guests that we've
wanted to come on and it's been like two
years of just constantly waiting and
waiting maybe it's gonna come maybe and
then now that we can fly out and maybe
like we are we are just basically it's
the floodgates just opening right and
it's just everyone coming on at once
because it's everyone that we've wanted
to come on and we've talked to before
about wanting to come on uh all coming
on at once so we're excited uh and it's
going to be a lot of fun I hope yeah I
think so a lot of big episodes back to
back I think yeah yeah yeah and we're
not just going to be uh filming yes
episodes we're going to be filming some
specials as well you're gonna have like
your first Trash taste specials abroad
as well we're not gonna spoil what those
specials are yeah but uh yeah we have to
be good yeah yeah yeah we have we have a
lot planned for trash taste yeah in the
coming months if you miss just us I'm
sure there'll be some episodes sprinkled
in there that are just the three of us
yeah yeah definitely yeah I know there's
a good uh a vocal Bunch on the summer
love the just us three episodes yeah
yeah and I guess they're so used to it
now so yeah especially it's such like an
interesting divide though right because
it's like you know in my head it's like
yeah the [ __ ] guest episodes are like
awesome because it's like a new person
New Perspective yeah whatever new topics
to talk about right but then there are a
lot of people who just like who like you
know
who this who this man I think we try to
make the guest episodes so even if you
don't know the guest you can kind of
they can come on right yeah I mean we've
had what three guest episodes before
this one right yeah so you know our
guest episodes aren't as personal so I
understand that people might not enjoy
them as much if that if that's what they
like most about trash taste yeah yeah
yeah it's obviously we can't go into a
lot about how we feel about things and
our own life because it's like oh we're
trying to make sure the vibe is good and
the guest can can Vibe yeah yeah exactly
well that's why we decided to just have
it the three of us when we started right
because of the light if we put a fourth
person in there not a whole lot of like
deep conversations yeah happening you
know there's gonna be like two it's
gonna be two on the surface I mean we're
clowns but we some sometimes we uh want
to not be clowns and just want to chill
and Vibe you know yeah surviving bro
just vibing sure we're clowns but we
also Vibe because as clowns as well
that's a clown Vibe
so I'm sure you'll be a fun fun America
stories while we're there yeah oh yeah
and I'm sure I'll gain well a lot of fun
UK stories as well yeah I'm sure God I'm
not looking forward to gaining weight
yeah I've been trying I've been trying
my [ __ ] hardest to not gain weight
before like obviously my wedding as well
yeah like it's it's really hard whenever
you travel out because one of the
hardest things is keeping to a schedule
right or getting to habits and like when
you're living in the same place and you
like build this habit you know you you
can stay on this habit and it's so much
easier but when you when there's like
even like a slight change in environment
or something you know
um it's so easy for just like one one
Domino to fall over and like everything
just Falls over oh yeah and you just
like slip into like the complete
opposite lifestyle of what you had I'm
trying my best to stay healthy right now
I've been like going to gym like every
day yeah just like working out because
I'm like I need I need to be healthy
before I go out there couldn't be me
I don't know I also want to get in cheap
as well so yeah I mean I feel more
energized when I've worked out yeah yeah
so I feel like I need that yeah I kind
of like the exercise bike every now and
then still like at home because we
bought one quite a while ago so like
whenever I have time I do that but like
yeah I don't know like again like I was
going to the gym for a while and then
just that one trip out for like a week
just completely throws everything out
yeah yeah yeah you know and then you
come back and you're like oh [ __ ] now I
gotta start from the scratch again you
know yeah and you're just like not
motivated at all yeah and that's just
like it's just a complete like habit
killer I don't know I'm kind of picky
like if the because some hotels are like
we have a gym yeah and you rock up to
this gym and it is literally like a
treadmill from the 80s that like is is
just so [ __ ] yeah and you're like well
okay I mean I guess I'll do that and
they got like no weights or anything you
know yeah okay all right I guess I'll
just run and then you just like okay and
then you go to the next place and
they're like we have a gym oh gyms
closed or something like it's just like
it's so hard to like can stay consistent
working out when you're traveling and
stuff that's definitely impossible I
didn't even try to pretend to try and
keep up I remember when I was going to
the gym crazy like when I lost the
majority of my weight like before I came
to Japan I was doing it while I was
going to the conventions and it's so
[ __ ] hard yeah waking up in the
morning before a convention and going to
the gym yeah oh my God it was so hard oh
my God and also bringing your Gym gear
with you yeah oh it's a pain in the ass
just bring your 75 dumbbells man yeah
that's all you need man that's all you
need you don't realize right in your
suitcase shoes take up a lot of room oh
yeah shoes are a painless and then also
shoes get dirty so I want to kind of
like cover them up yeah just like pain
in the ass and you've got to bring gym
clothes which you're not gonna wear any
other time okay any other time like I
remember before when I used to travel
I'd be like I'd have to use like the
weight limit to its [ __ ] maximum
right of course like like you'd have to
pack as much as you can and if you if
you don't then you could squeeze in more
there but now like I want to pack as
light as possible right and like shoes
are the most like annoying things right
it's so annoying they're like because
they're light but they take up the most
space what the thing is are they light
some sometimes shoes aren't like I mean
if they're packing like boots like yeah
you're back in like [ __ ] Doc Martens
then yeah like I need like separate
luggages because because like here's the
thing like you normally pack extra pairs
of shoes with you
the everyday shoes yeah nice shoes yeah
it depends where I'm going right
sometimes like if I'm going to like say
like a completely different like if I'm
going somewhere that's like really
summery and beachy then yeah you know
I'll take like a couple of like
flip-flops
they aren't shoes but like you know if
I'm going somewhere and I know I need to
go to like a fancy dinner or something
then you know I'll bring some like dress
shoes yeah yeah that's and and they are
just like the most fiddliest things
trying to [ __ ] fit in your in your
life but if I just need like a pair of
sneakers then I'm just taking the one
pair of sneakers yeah yeah like how many
jeans do you bring How many pairs of
trousers do you bring oh one pouches
yeah because yeah one pair of jeans
because I'm just like for some reason
it's it's so weird I like to bring like
10 t-shirts five hoodies or whatever and
I'm like do I need an extra pair of
jeans sometimes the answer is no you
know
sure there's people going around asking
people how much underwear they brought
for like a five-day trip right and I was
just like I was shocked is it not five
yeah yeah well how much would you bring
to a five-day trip How many pairs of
underwear okay like
like it's five minimum but sometimes I'm
like maybe I need that extra pair of
underwear maybe I'll [ __ ] it's not
underwear it's socks How many pairs of
socks do you bring oh I always bring
extra socks wait why because you know
you might run into an instance where
like say wherever you are is raining for
instance right your socks get wet you
don't want to wear those wet socks for
the rest of the day okay I'm doing my
underwear all right okay underwear for
me if it's a five day trip I'm bringing
Max six how much you guys bringing how
much you guys bringing your five-day
trips
six right yeah six socks underwear
underwear How many pairs
like like like for me the amount of
socks in the amount of underwear you
bring should be equal right yes yes yes
your face was just like yeah yeah yeah
yeah on this video people are like eight
nine ten eleven and then like three
yeah like one yeah whoa but like eight
what is happening are you bringing eight
pairs of under what has happened like
double up right like I'm I'm sorry like
unless like when you're working out it's
a different story right because you're
playing the workout I get it because I
when I work out I'm running through
socks and underwear yeah yeah of course
I'm I'm not re-wearing that underwear
yeah yeah yeah it starts because she's
like [ __ ] I only got half a day out of
this underwear yeah I [ __ ] wash it
yeah it kind of sucks you know but like
if you're if you're just going on a trip
why do you need more than five pairs
does it make any sense it also depends
on the climate because if you're going
to like especially like a Southeast
Asian country you are sweating through
that [ __ ] underwear man
you're taking like four showers a day
yeah yeah the swamp ass man is just like
it's on another level you need you need
those extra pairs of underwear man but
like this is like in America yeah I
think there's a single place in America
we need more than five pairs of
underwear I guess unless you're going on
like a five-day trip to like Death
Valley you know maybe like I just think
that like you know whatever and I've
been trying to like you know like I said
I'm trying to minimize but also yeah
yeah did you ever try and uh do anything
sneaky with your suitcase to the airport
you would try to like get past the
weight limit how so uh
one time I don't know which airport it
was in the the thing where the suitcase
was yeah there was no other staff to
this side yeah it was just the person
there behind the desk yeah and uh I had
the suitcase just like the suitcase I
had was kind of like uh the wheels were
kind of like not centered not on the
edge but like kind of sent going towards
the center so the edge was leaning off
yeah and so I'll just do that thing
where you just like put your foot and
just like slightly lift it up to like
get a kilogram or two off and then just
hold it like like some kind of nen user
yeah yeah you've got to have the
conversation while just slightly holding
it because it was it was going to go
over yeah I knew it was over because on
the way there it was over yeah on the
way back how much was it like five
kilograms okay so you're not getting
away with that so I no I did huh I got
it down to like it was just 20 kg limit
right yeah it was going to like 24 25.
yeah who are you flying with mostly
Airlines have 20 kg on one bag limit
it's another 23 normally 20 I actually
depends on the airline
sometimes yeah something 15 as well okay
so I I was like I I need to show you
five off this bad boy right now and it
was solar cars dude it was so hard
because I'm like I'm like on the desk
like this trying to get my documents and
I'm like I'm like my foot is like steel
right yeah like lifting it up but you've
got to keep it even because if it's
wobbling they know what you're doing
yeah yeah but like what I figure like
what are they gonna do they're gonna
kick me off the plane if they find out
I'm doing it it just reminds me of like
you know in JoJo where they put the
chocolate under the water right so I
changed the level of it while you're
just having a conversation because it's
like I've been [ __ ] with you this in
times you because I had to pay the fee
on the way back yeah I have any other
way of taking it they charged me like 70
or something yeah the flight was like
300 yeah I was broke yeah yeah I
couldn't afford 70. so I was like I'm
gonna do this bro yeah it was like a
JoJo like fight there I was like holding
it up with my like left foot yeah on the
desk doing my passport getting the
ticket it was like no need
put it on and when I put it on I just
kept talking to her yeah it seemed like
nothing was I wasn't that close to it
either but like this she because the
desk was really tall yeah and there was
no one else
there's no one behind me and I'm scared
that someone would call me out but no
one did so yeah it all worked nicely so
if there was someone behind you they
would have just been like damn yeah yeah
I I if somebody called me yeah I'd have
been like what is wrong with you yeah
let me you are you you want to be [ __ ]
over by them too come on but one time I
will say uh when I was moving to Japan
and I had like three suitcases the woman
was like my suitcases were like way over
yeah because I had like my computer
gearing yeah so it was like it was like
10 15 kg over yeah and she just like
looked at me and I was like I must look
really sad because I was like I was like
I'm moving and she's like
all right I won't tell anyone don't you
just let it off sometimes I love when
they do yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because
because like they're so hard so because
like here's the thing like I I've had to
like do similar things but I tried to
prepare as much as possible yeah before
I go again so you you weigh it and
you're just like how much how much can
you like physically bring on a carry-on
okay right like you push that to the
Limit because you have you have a
carry-on and then sometimes you can have
like a bag which is not too big or it
doesn't look too big you know you know
but like you you push the limits about
how much you can have on a carry-on and
a personal personal item is that's what
it's called right yeah right so you you
have to spread things as equally as
possible and I noticed like the magic
number is between like 0.5 and 1
kilograms right if it's between if it's
over by like less than like one kilogram
or just like like I've met airlines that
is like if it's exactly one kilogram
they will charge you but if it's like
0.9 they're just like we'll let it go
we'll let it go the the the 0.1
kilograms makes a big difference I I
that just reminded me of like the time
when I got stranded in Canada right one
time because I lost my passport right so
I don't know if I've told this story in
trash days but like like yeah like this
is like five six years ago I went I went
to uh I went to a con in Montreal and uh
and you know I was like hanging out with
a bunch of mates or whatever and then I
was flying back to Australia but I had
to stop buying Toronto first so I was
like Montreal to Toronto and then
Toronto back to Sydney right so then I
got to Montreal Airport and I was like I
can't find my [ __ ] passport
and you know this is the first time ever
I've lost my passport let alone overseas
right yeah which is [ __ ] terrifying
yeah I find out later that my friend who
was with me at the con the entire time
I'd accidentally put my passport in his
bag and he had already flown home back
to like I think he lives in like San
Jose or something right so he was
already in America with my passport in
his bag man and so I got to Montreal
Airport that's like nightmare it was it
was a [ __ ] nightmare I forgot to cry
yeah like and like I got to Montreal
Airport I told them the situation they
were like all right what you can do is
that there's an Australian Embassy in
Toronto anyway yeah so just we'll let
you fly to Toronto at least but then you
we're gonna have to but then you're
gonna have to find a hotel go to the
Embassy get a new passport right right
so you know I'm [ __ ] freaking out
right so I fly to Toronto get put in a
hotel
and then my friend who had the possible
was like I can try and like email like
not email email
I can try it I can try and this like
send this to you like mail it to you
right through like FedEx whatever but
like I don't know how long it's gonna
take right not to mention it's
technically in a different country yeah
so it has to go through like customs and
[ __ ] yeah right
I stayed in that hotel for five days
straight God every day I'm FedEx took
five days five days bro bro he's like
cheap out no no no no no no it was stuck
in customs for like three and a half
days so it got to Canada like on the
morning of day two but because it's just
a passport yeah it was literally just
stuck in customs for like three whole
days what the [ __ ] are they doing I
don't know checking it was legitimate or
something like no illegal activities
whatever but like I do it like I was so
[ __ ] depressed because like I'm stuck
in this area in this hotel in the middle
of Toronto I don't know anyone who lives
there right yeah I wake up in the
morning and I'm literally sitting in
front of the reception phone just hoping
that I get a call being like you've got
a package right I hope you had an
ergonomic keyboard no I didn't
I was like 75
you were training up for covid man so
like so the first thing I had to do
though was I had to go to Toronto
Airport to like change my flight right
like hey I've lost my passport I don't
know what to do and it was like this
like Canadian woman who was there and
she was like okay
um you know because it's an unfortunate
situation we can change your flight for
free if you fly tomorrow right and you
know I didn't know when this package was
gonna arrive right so I was just like
okay yeah sure let's do that yeah you
know just so I don't get my flight
completely canceled yeah of course next
day happens it doesn't arrive yeah so
then the next day I had to go back to
Toronto Airport and the same woman was
there right and she was like okay if you
want to change it to like two or three
days later which is the next available
flight it's gonna cost you like you know
a couple of thousand dollars yeah right
and at the time you know because I'd
only just started doing YouTube I didn't
have that kind of money you know I was
still living off [ __ ] scraps yeah for
YouTube ad rev and Saul was like and you
know I I was like on the verge of tears
I was like on the verge I'd be crying
already like I was on the verge of tears
and just being like
I I was just like I don't have that kind
of money right now and I was like what
do I do should I call my mom but it's
like three in the morning in Australia
right now blah blah blah blah and then
the woman just like kind of like was
just looking at me panicking for a
little bit and this just starts typing
away on a keyboard and then she prints
out this ticket
for two days to go and she hands it to
me and then she just I'll never forget
it she just says I better not see you
here ever again and she just gave me
this free tip dude I [ __ ] cry I just
like I like I got on my knees and I just
broke down crying because this lady just
literally just gave me this two thousand
dollars just because she felt sorry for
me yeah and I'm like that would never
happen in Japan in Japan it's like hold
on I gotta call up the manager and then
the managers
they will never let it happen so like
luckily two days later I got the [ __ ]
you know passport and I got the package
and I [ __ ] ripped that [ __ ] open to
the hotel room saw my passport broke
down crying again because I'm like
finally I can go home and then yeah I
got to Toronto Airport and I got my
flight back and I was like whoever you
were lady I will never [ __ ] forget
you that was like that was the moment
where I was like you know what People
Are Awesome there is there is a God I I
can confirm that that would never happen
in Japan yeah uh because I that I didn't
have that much of a stressful situation
uh but something kind of similar
happened to me recently yeah so uh
recently we uh we went on a trip
together uh and after the trip I was
meant to fly to America uh fly to
America to uh meet Sydney's family
because I haven't seen them since before
covert so I wanted to see them once
before I get married and become one big
happy family uh so I had the tickets
booked and because the schedule was so
tight I had pre-packed all of my travel
stuff before going on the trip with the
boys basically
um Sydney uh flew out I believe like a
week before me so she she had she had
she had flown off already right uh and I
remember I packed everything before and
I put my passport in my travel bag right
and uh it's and I remember coming home
and I remember being absolutely
knackered from coming back from this uh
boys trip
um and then I was just like checking
everything was ready to go ready to fly
in like a day or two
um and then I noticed the bag is missing
oh oh [ __ ] and then I start panicking
because I know the most like if there's
one document I need it's my passport
yeah right especially because I'm
getting married in two months I can't
believe my [ __ ] passport I need to
fly back to the UK
um like such [ __ ] searching around
the house and everything and I'm just
like she better not have she better not
have and I phoned her I phone her and uh
she's she's asleep and it's um it's 2 am
right she's wake the [ __ ] up I give her
like I give her like 10 phone calls like
she's not picking up phone her mom she's
not picking up luckily luckily um
luckily her dad was still awake luckily
I'm just like Russell I need to do I
need you to do me a massive favor uh can
you wake Sydney up now can you wake
Sydney up right now right now I'm sorry
he rushes over he wakesed me up I'm like
Sydney do you have the bag do you have
the bag Sydney and she's like yeah I was
like Sydney Sydney this is not the time
to be asleep you need to wake up now I
need to check that you have the [ __ ]
Oscar travel bag okay do you have it and
she's just like
um yeah yeah I have it I'm like is my
passport in there and she's she's like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm so I'm so like she
like
like I don't know why she had never used
this bike which like this is the one
time she decided to use this as a travel
bag
um and unfortunately she didn't check
the contents of the bag so it doesn't
check her bag
there's like nothing else in the fair
was it just the passport in the back uh
it was my passport and my other like
vaccine travel documents that I needed
so basically all everything you needed
so so everything I needed to travel out
of Japan
so he was like empty aside from like the
front pocket which had like literally
like the one that everything I needed in
my life I'm your proof for existence
yeah existence to Japan right and so I'm
and so we're like trying to like plan
this out to be like can I make this
flight if I if we like do a frame
perfect like frame perfect drop of this
to like [ __ ] DHL right away like and
we're like what's the closest DHL okay
so it's it's this place we can go home
you can you can wake up tomorrow and go
get it and then I realized unfortunately
it's America and
um they don't they don't work on the
weekends yeah so I'm like oh [ __ ] I have
to wait two days before they can even
put the drop off even if even if DHL are
like super on point which they were
actually DHL were like very fast
um I'm still not gonna get it in time so
I have to like uh if I want to go to
America he's the Strat yeah I have to
like delay I have to like change the
flight right uh so that was stressful
enough not having my passport on me
right yeah
um so I remember phoning up a a
to be like look I'm I'm in the situation
now like I don't know if I don't know if
I qualify for a change of flight because
the thing is like I believe I I bought a
flexible ticket right right so so I I
wasn't I wasn't I didn't buy one on like
I didn't I didn't buy a ticket on like
some random [ __ ] website I bought it
from a a itself right
um and so I thought paying like a bit of
a premium price as opposed to buying
from like [ __ ] Skyscanner or whatever
that I you know there was a little bit
of wiggle room on that right yeah
um because it wasn't a cheap ticket and
like like I don't know why flying to
America right now is so [ __ ]
expensive from like everywhere because
it was it was it was like the cheap the
cheapest economy ticket they had and it
was still like [ __ ] like almost like
a grand or like two grand I can't I
can't [ __ ] remember it's like yeah
one way yeah yeah yeah it was on one-way
flights they're weirdly expensive return
flights are like weirdly more like less
experience yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
something to do with how long you're
gone on and there's there's different
price points based on if you're flying
with the same carrier and how far apart
you're flying so yeah there's some
really strange rules for the ticket
prices yeah so I I find up a a and I'm
like look here's his situation can I
change my flights uh can I change my
flight to you know a day a few days
after or whatever's whatever's
convenient and they're like yes there's
a flight on X day uh that's still
available I still got seats and I'm like
great can I change to that flight um how
much how much would it cost would it
cost anything and I remember her like
hearing like the
and then
she pauses and she pauses and she's just
like
um hold on can I I need to go see the
manager quickly oh my god um and I'm
like that's that's that's not a good
sign that's not a good fighting in Japan
yeah yeah anything needs to manage it
yeah yeah cause I'm like oh man how how
many hundreds of dollars am I gonna have
to like [ __ ] pay to like change my
flights yeah um and then like I wait for
like five minutes I'm like okay you know
I can afford like a few hundred dollars
luckily enough
um because I really want to go see their
family
um and then she comes back
and then uh and then she's like okay I
have just confirmed to my manager if you
would like to change uh your plane
ticket to this date uh it is four
thousand dollars
what and um and I was I was like uh can
can you can you repeat that right could
you repeat that
could could you repeat could you repeat
that
because because they because they said
it in because they said it in Yen right
because I said in Yen I was just like
400 000 years yeah so I was like uh my
my again my my Japanese must be rusty
because I think I think there's I I must
have missed that must have been some
static yeah because I think like is is
that what it is in Japanese I must have
added an extra zero in my head because
that is that is not 400 000 Yen I must
have heard forty thousand yen yeah and
uh just misheard so I was like could you
repeat that please and then they
repeated that and now I was just like so
to confirm in English that is 400 000
Yen right because I'm like it's like I'm
like Manny hunger is not Josie enough
I'm coping right now mind hunger is
definitely not josu enough right now I'm
just hearing this right oh my God and
um and she was and and then she was like
yes it is 400 000 uh Yen and I was like
how is this possible and and and and she
was like uh I apologize
um because because it's it's it's
there's a small change fee and like the
tax is different like I couldn't
understand like no matter what she says
there is no justification for an
increase in four it performs like a flex
ticket and somehow it ended up costing
more than the original ticket yeah yeah
like you're not you're not you didn't
like upgrade to business class right no
no no like that's that's the kind of
prices this was economy and I was just
like is that 4 000 Yen on top of the two
like oh no so is that a thousand yeah is
that like 4 000 on top of the ticket
that I just already paid for and she was
like yes
wow so so so it's a five thousand dollar
one week yeah yeah yeah and and so like
I'm like there is no [ __ ] way this
makes sense so I go on [ __ ]
Skyscanner like I I as as they're on the
call as we're on the call and I'm just
like I can see I can buy a ticket on
your website for two thousand dollars
like a new ticket for two thousand
dollars how does it make sense that
you're charging me four thousand dollars
to change my ticket change it change it
right and she was like I apologize sir
it's just that's just how the system
works it's the up charge for changing
the tickets and I'm just like okay
so it's cheaper for me to buy a new
ticket even if it's like double the
price at this point from what I
originally paid can I get a refund for
the original picadite for the original
ticket I paid
um
for the original ticket I paid uh in
order to get to get the refund back so I
can buy a new ticket yeah and she was
like oh yes uh the uh
the cancellation fee or free 900 900.
[Music]
flexible tickets means you can change it
you can't refund it some of them let you
some of them you can change it some of
them do and I was just like
am I talking to the circus right now
like that's I don't like that I didn't
say that but that's what I wanted to say
you're not the clown you want a whole
circus
oh my God so so my choices are either to
pay four thousand dollars uh to change
my ticket or to to or to to like get 900
to pay 900 to cancel with tickets uh and
then buy a two thousand dollar ticket a
new two thousand dollar ticket and I'm
just like I am not doing this like at
like so
for the first time in my life I was like
can I speak to the manager
like I like because the thing is I am
not the type of guy who goes Karen of
course I am all the type of guy yeah but
they were taking the piss I mean I think
anyone in that situation would go Karen
mode yeah that's [ __ ] ridiculous yeah
yeah like so I asked for the manager and
like it was the reasoning for like the
up charge of that much is because I
wanted the flights within like if if I
if I had waited I believe like I thought
I believe like eight days eight or nine
days then it would be a lot cheaper
because there was this like window yeah
where I wanted to change the flight to
even though there were flights available
and the flight tickets which was cheaper
to buy new changing to that changing to
within that date range meant that they
had to up charge the tickets right so
and there was nothing that which still
doesn't make sense yes which still
doesn't make sense so there was nothing
there was nothing I could do about it I
I talked to the manager I was like look
is there anything you can do at all
because I like I'm not I'm not lying but
this is ridiculous yeah you are not
giving me any way out you you are not
giving me a solution my solution is I
pay 900 to pay two thousand dollars
like like you you're not it's literally
like the enter the lottery to buy the
tickets yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so so unfortunately I didn't get a
solution I lost a thousand I I lost 900
uh to cancel my ticket and I flew to
England for a fraction of the price for
this headache to go to America Christ
um so yeah unfortunately
um I don't know I don't know what's
going on with flights to America it's
insane right now yeah
Flash from the UK to America as well
it's crazy expensive really wow [ __ ]
yeah meanwhile flights to from Tokyo to
London were like it was like one
thousand dollars for business so what
the [ __ ] going on what's Happening no
one's wanting to go to the UK right I
think no one wants to go from Tokyo as
well oh that's true yeah but okay I got
because I got to ask now hey just remind
me have you guys ever gone full Karen
have you guys ever needed to like ask
for the manager
I'm not the kind of person to like go to
a restaurant and be like wow my soup is
20 minutes late yeah yeah but I feel
like I normally try to like I I when I'm
talking in those situations I'd only try
to build up some rapport with the person
I'm talking to yeah yeah I don't
normally be like yo listen uh you know I
nothing can be done and I'll be like I
mean I'll take your word for it yeah yes
like you know I feel there's like if
there is a problem with some kind of
service or you know situation there's
only so much that I know the manager can
do anyway so I'm just like don't just
don't even bother like yeah I'll just
I'll fold I don't give a [ __ ] like it's
not it's not a life or death situation
in that situation I I'd be tempted to
but even then I'm like I'm so lazy that
I'm like all right I guess I also don't
want to cause a scene you know even
though I'm perfectly in the right to
cause a scene because I'm the one
getting [ __ ] over like there's a part
there's a part of me that's just like no
I don't wanna I don't wanna like be the
[ __ ] yeah you know so it's like yeah
I don't know I don't think I've ever no
I never don't have but I mean I don't
think like I don't know it's weird
because like if you call the scene
sometimes you get what you want yeah
yeah right because it's like I don't I'd
just rather not I've I've been in
situations where you just treat me like
a human being yeah I've been in
situations where I've been in like a
restaurant or whatever and I've seen
someone else cause a scene they get what
they want yeah I'm just like what an
[ __ ] yeah yeah because because the
thing is like it's it's because I I
hardly ever go full Karen
um but I've seen I've seen it work I
just like I could I I don't have the
ability to do that myself yes because I
remember like on this trip back to
England uh there was this point where we
were on it we're on a night out uh we're
with all our friends right
um and Sydney was tired and so like I I
took her home like took her home like
earlier everyone else went on drinking
and eventually they ended up in a casino
right yeah uh and so I was like cool I'm
not tired yet I'm is it cool if I go out
to you know continue with my mates and
continue drinking have fun and then I
was like yeah uh Sydney was already
passed us I was like cool I'm just gonna
go please make noise
don't hear anything yeah
absolutely and so there was a sizable
group
um inside the casino yeah uh so I get
there and I want to go in and uh there's
a bouncer at the door uh and he's just
like sorry you can't come in unless you
remember and I was just like but I know
you've let uh plenty of other people in
because my entire my entire friend group
is in there yeah
um and uh my entire my entire friend
group is in there and they weren't
members uh so what's that what's
happening with that and he was like oh
you know uh he was like sorry no members
right now uh uh no entry right now until
unless you remember yeah and I was just
like oh I I know like I know he can let
me in you know like it's not like a
massive casino and the thing is I see
people walking out you know I I see like
plenty of people walking out and I like
you know when you can tell like that
there's a bouncer who just wants to go
on a power trip oh yeah like you know
what I mean you know what I mean I like
I knew it wasn't like it wasn't like
devote like it wasn't like the busiest
place in London or whatever it was it
was it was a place that I knew the
bouncer was just trying to be an [ __ ]
because like I could clearly see there
are people walking in and out yeah right
and there are people that were going out
and saying that they were leaving and so
I was just like okay what is the right
angle to go for to try and get myself in
right if you want to see your friends
yeah because I really because I'm like
everyone see my friends uh because the
night we wasn't even like that late
um
was it a Saturday or like a Tuesday
um I believe it was a Sunday oh I can't
understand maybe if it was Saturday it
was really busy you know we want to
limit it to customers then they were
going to spend a [ __ ] ton of money yeah
it wasn't even like that busy right no
it was it wasn't even that business
because because like so I'm like I'm
like okay I gotta at least try to get in
right yeah because uh if I don't get in
I gotta I didn't get to say goodbye to
my friends and like my night's over so
I'm at least like try to get in uh and
of course I don't go full Karen I go I
try to go
so I go I go for the friendly approach
you know like start from at the moment
right yeah the the Rapport approach
right the the Rapport approach the
dieters approach there's nothing wrong
with like being like trying to explain
like yeah you know maybe if there's not
like a giant line behind you like listen
I wanna I wanna see my friends
calmly explain
look mate like I understand that you
don't want like a big group of like
strangers coming in or whatever at this
time of the hour you know I get that you
know you you're just like you got you
got some rules that you need to follow
and everything like that
um look I'll be honest I'm just one guy
I'm not local around here because I've
literally flown in from Japan just to
hang out with my mates and I don't get
this chance often yeah
um and I was I was just I was just like
the sympathy approach because I was
because I was like dude I'm not here to
like ruin you now spend [ __ ] money
yeah you know I I know you just don't
want some [ __ ] random deck here just
like walking and everything like that I
am not that random [ __ ] I'm not
drunk you know I'm I'm like I'm like a
good I'm a good boy I'm a good boy
yeah yeah that is very very well
definitely like like I was trying to be
as well [ __ ] spoken as possible it
was this was like me me like putting on
like The Tuxedo like it's the way it's
100 but like but like [ __ ] you know this
guy just was not having it like he was
like something else is like that they're
just like you know she was like no
they're not having it because because
the thing is he would not even like even
have a conversation like he was like no
I can I can get it because they probably
deal with like some really [ __ ] awful
I I get it I get it at the same time
it's like sometimes you're like yeah
dude I'm I'm not I'm not the problem
here dude yeah yeah everyone causing you
problems yeah yeah yeah yes maybe I am
by talking YouTube yeah yeah exactly I
was just like look look you know and
eventually I was just like you know find
it you know fine I guess you know I
guess I guess my night's over and then
one of my one of my friends comes out
right
and uh she sees what's going on she's
like what's going on here and I was like
they have some rules and
um the balance is just like not
communicating with me at all I don't
think there's any way to get in and
she's like bet she's like
Karen mode actively
like that was like an instant like 50
like an instant switch to be like
um excuse me yeah like do you know that
he's getting married in a month awesome
she's just gonna be a lady do you know
who he is yeah yeah he's the anime Zone
the greatest YouTuber and she goes and
and she's able to just like go on this
like some somehow yeah I just probably
want to get rid of her yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] off it's like
this [ __ ] five minute rant right it's
like you know it's it's like you know uh
when it's like Senator Armstrong is just
like standing there and you're like it's
just like [ __ ] like pulling the
punches and he's just it's not punching
yeah he's not budging But like after
about five minutes he's just like fine
you can go in I was just like stop what
that what I I thought I thought being
like the nice guy would work but just
like [ __ ] like go like just like no
like just going full Karen and just like
like hauling from the manager and just
like not letting up that works sometimes
that's but I think that's the thing
right it's like I think the reason why I
don't go Karen mode like ever is because
I've been on the other side of that
before like when I used to work yeah
yeah yeah and like oh my God I still
remember this [ __ ] to this day but
like it was it was this absolute knob
head who like he came in I was working
when I was working up at the ski Fields
I was working behind a bar some nights
and you know I had to pour like beers
and [ __ ] and whatever yeah but then of
course the this this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] walks in with like 10 of his
mates right and he was like and he said
could you come here for a second yeah
you love me for a second I was like oh
you're talking to me all right yeah
whatever that's a bit weird and uh and
then he's like can we get 20 B-52s
please
and to explain what a B-52 is it's this
liqueur shot that's three layers right
yes and so the layering [ __ ] I don't if
you've ever made layering stuff you've
got to like slowly pour it at the back
of a spoon otherwise it mixes right yeah
so in other words making one of these
takes a long time yeah because you know
you want to make it look nice right and
this [ __ ] was like 20 of them
please and I was like okay sure I was
the only one at the bar right yeah so I
was like all right I better start
[ __ ] slaving away at it then but you
know because it's you know a restaurant
right and like a bar I wanted to like
look nice I'm not just gonna [ __ ]
pour it in right yeah I start pouring
you know a couple of them and then
around like the third one that I'm
making this [ __ ] just walks into the
bar and he was like oh where the [ __ ]
are the B-52s
I was like get your manager and I was
like [ __ ] you want to make it
you want to be my guest be my guest
[ __ ] make it right now you want to
make it any faster than me do you want
them or not you haven't even paid for it
yet I don't even have to make it for you
and so of course but you know that's
what I said in my head right but on the
outside I was like I'll get the medicine
right away
so then the magic
the
manager
and then I call the manager over and
she's like this Japanese lady right but
like you know who looks really nice on
the outside but on the inside she's like
a reverse character because you have to
deal with like she has to deal with
[ __ ] like this all right yeah so
then she comes out and you know this
nice like you know short Japanese lady
comes out and she's like oh what seems
to be the problem and you know this guy
starts going off being like yo so he's
[ __ ] taking forever making these
drinks you know like we've been waiting
forever by forever he they mean like you
know 10 minutes yeah right and I've
never seen someone Go reverse Karen yeah
on a customer before yeah and she was
just like um excuse me do you want to
make these I don't think so so give him
some [ __ ] time I love videos of like
the employees of fast food places yeah
yeah just being like and and she was
just like she literally was like get out
yeah good yeah yeah and you know he was
you know going off and being like this
is the worst place ever [ __ ] you guys
it's just like I don't give a [ __ ] get
out get the [ __ ] out right now and I was
like and you know because I was like
okay and it's too shy and like scared to
like say anything so in the back I was
like yeah
think every time you know I'm in a
situation where you know perhaps
something is laid or you know where most
people would want to go Karen mode in
some situations I always remember that
situation I'm like no I don't want to be
that [ __ ] yeah I'll wait but because
because like the part of the reason that
I was like because I got like slightly
annoyed at the bouncer wasn't wasn't
because of the fact that he wasn't
letting me in but because like he just
refused to like engage with me yeah so
because I wouldn't explain it to you
yeah he just wouldn't explain it to me
because like I could like I could tell
he was just like he he probably had a
bad day or something or I don't [ __ ]
know but like he was just he just wanted
to exert his power upon someone like I I
could I could feel that energy because
like I've been to like places before
where you talk to The Bouncer and they
explain to you like look look like
there's nothing I can do you know like I
don't I I don't feel like trying to help
you yeah I'd be like I get it because
I'm like I'm a human as well but like I
was like he was like nah gotta
prioritize our members and I was looking
around I was like thinking what [ __ ]
members it's you and me I was like there
is no line here there is no line there's
no line of people waiting to come up I
know for a fact uh because after I went
in the casino was like 90 empty so I was
just like what I was just like you know
this is an [ __ ] being an [ __ ] and
this is like the only thing that could
beat an [ __ ] is a Karen and like
Unstoppable forces
you know those YouTube videos where
they're like yeah just like bribe your
way into everything yeah yeah you want
an upgrade at a hotel room just slip the
person 50 bucks yeah I've always thought
about stuff like that because I'm like
I'd love to be able to have the
slickness and the coolness to pull that
[ __ ] off but I'm just thinking like how
do I how do I discreetly just give you
like 10 pounds in a way that like
doesn't make me look [ __ ] stupid yeah
what if you say no to me right and then
I'm like oh give me a second just pull
out 10 notes
I would have to preemptively give him
some money and that point what if no one
else paid money to get in and I'm the
[ __ ] who gave him 10 pounds yeah and
alternatively what if you go to like
that whole I see all those [ __ ] tick
tocks just give your hotel checking
person 50 bucks like it's like okay what
if the hotel should actually fall like
you actually just gave them 50 and
you're a dude I've seen that before
though where like I saw a guy at like a
club or like a bar or something yeah who
like you know did like the whole
[ __ ] being like like pulls out at 20
and like puts it into the you know
bounces like pocket yeah and the bouncer
looks at it and he's like all right give
me a second I'm gonna go talk to the
manager about it yeah and he goes in he
comes out and he's like sorry we're full
and so and then everyone in the lines
just starts laughing being like I want
to dig in I've seen it work and not work
yeah yeah I've seen when it doesn't work
it's hilarious yeah yeah but that's that
to me it's like all right the the
benefits don't outweigh the the absolute
humility of getting rejected yeah yeah
yeah trying to for money to someone to
get into something it's like you not
only lost money but you also didn't get
what you wanted yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's some people who like have their
I think they have the personality that
matches up to that kind of behavior oh
yeah I I'm not slick at all I can't
remember this stuff I can't do that I've
been with guys who are just like well
let's uh let's come to a solution and
then they like [ __ ] give the 10. yeah
I was like just just say shut up
I've not seen Jen do it but I know Jen
it's like like John has the energy that
he could pull it off no Joanna's the
energy he can pull it off without ever
getting his wallet out yeah he's just
like let's talk Jen would do it get
rejected and then not care that he was
rejected yeah just be like okay we'll go
somewhere else yeah but to me it's like
that's crushing and bad yeah I can't I
can't do that you tell me it's full I
don't have a magical Karen that appears
to sort it out for me I guess I don't
have like cameras
I don't have like a stand I can pull it
out
I guess I'm done
yeah cause like I'm just going for
trying to be a clown a little bit maybe
I'll feel like that was funny I'll let
this guy yeah I try and like I try and
like human my way through things because
it doesn't work no it doesn't think
about those bribes that I've seen it's
just like how do you how do you know how
much to give you know like like how like
how what's the right amount to bribe
someone of like well if you're trying to
get a situation and you know a Michelin
star restaurant I I don't have that at
work it doesn't make any sense but like
a club if there's a [ __ ] Club maybe you
just give them like I don't know we've
got six pins and I want two drinks yeah
many people who do this often no there's
a system I don't know there's like a
tier list right yeah maybe they can
explain it to me how it works especially
how nice or expensive the drinks are
yeah I've never heard of being rejected
from a casino though that's and only
like drunk people get rejection casinos
normally your Tipsy gone I was not too
sure like
he was like two bottles
that's how I remember at least
I'm sure it came out hello my name is
to enter this establishment meanwhile
others learned from Japan
[Laughter]
well you said you just take Sydney home
right so odds are you probably even if
you did drink you'd probably [ __ ]
show it out yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was a good night we uh we we went
to casino it was a happy end to the
story and it was the one time in my life
that uh seeing someone go go for Karen
uh was impressive and it actually worked
as well not that I would ever have the
balls to do with myself no I I I I was
just starting there
um and I was just I was impressed that's
what everyone needs though no like not
ever like you you don't need to be a
Karen you just need to know a Karen yeah
that's that's all you need you just need
that one mate who will be the man when
they work for me
parents Karen suck unless you can tell
them to do something that you want okay
no no no Kara suck unless the the
manager or the person is being an equal
[ __ ] exactly yeah you know like I I
normally I don't advocate for this like
at all because you know service people
go through enough you know
people when people I see videos people
like arguing at McDonald's asking for
free food I'm like what happened at
Birth that you became like this like how
did how did you how are you dropped hard
enough yeah to go to a McDonald's and
like berate a 14 year old kid just like
being a brat about it right like they're
probably a brat their entire life there
are only very few points and some and
like yeah if if the service person is
being an [ __ ] yes you should be a
coward even though I still don't have it
in me even if there have been plenty of
points where I'm like I should go for
Karen you know because there have been
plenty of points where they have been
the [ __ ] yeah and I'm totally within
my rights to go full character but like
it's just it's just so hard man it's
it's so hard luckily Google reviews
exists okay
you know like that [ __ ] who ordered
the 20 b52s I would have loved to have
like Snapped back at him yeah but I just
I couldn't imagine yeah okay I didn't
have the balls yeah or or when you well
when they tell you you have to you get
charged four thousand dollars to change
your ticket
absolute absolute stale absolute state
so yeah bottom line uh just don't be a
Karen just know it Karen yeah
I have to beat my staff Karen that's
when you can do it if it bounces like
being a dick into you just be like oh
you're approaching me come on in
oh my God Karen's just really standing
standing here
get an organ on my keyboard and I can
get a Karen I guess you can tell when to
shut up yeah all right thank you so much
for watching this episode
look at these patrons oh my God Dental
Karen's they don't care because they
support us unless they know the exact
point to be to be a cow unless they have
like a Karen mode yeah but hey if you
like to support the show then make sure
to go over to our patreon patreon.com
trashcase also follow us on Twitter send
us a memes on the subreddit and if you
hate our face listen to us on Spotify
and uh yeah from Next Episode we won't
be here no we're gonna be somewhere else
somewhere out there in the world yeah I
mean we'll still be here on YouTube you
you will see us next week you know uh
but we just won't be here in the studio
yeah we'll be in another hey and check
out my brand as well same with slugs the
end all right we'll catch you guys next
week bye
[Music]